hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play gary dark secrets
alright so we got oh welcome to leave
missus battery and a note
I've sent hours ago to carry out some
routine errands in the underground area
but I still haven't figured out how to
get through this room the security down
here is ridiculously high it's a good
thing we hardly use this route anymore
if anyone from the security staff reads
this then lower the damn security level
otherwise I will be forced to take this
up with Thomas personally and bring some
rat poison it's disgusting with all the
rats down here too much no joke we just
got Wyatt oh wait no I did it already I
unlocked the thingy because of the doors
or the books I got the books cuz I'm so
smart
oh what's that sound
some kind of machine I would assume so
batteries I'm fine
I know ah hi there
the machinery is really old why would
they have it down here maybe because
it's a castle and a castle is old don't
ask questions you don't want the answer
to
I've had enough of your disingenuous
assertion
hi oh boy Oh ain't that fun it's a water
monster what's that over there
it's berry doesn't do [ __ ] or this
flashlight doesn't do [ __ ] a torch if
you're in England land oh no I'm gonna
flip on the water and fall into the
water all right whatever ice doesn't
seem so bad it's not like they're making
me go in hello hallo nope
nuttin ninguna I do paintings can't you
I can't hide in there alright nothing
there nothing there I don't know what my
next objective is but then again I
hardly ever do in these amnesia moths
Kurt UNK
her junk
there's nothing in here just uh there
are a lot of rooms in this mod where it
just seems like there's no point it's
just here for decoration like I could
have easily walked by this room I guess
but still have like maybe a battery or
something in there just a little
something a reward for my exploration oh
boy
Lee oh epic Oh super skilled oh yeah
anything stuff for the water hmm hoping
for something behind here - man I'm like
used to the other - never slake where
everywhere I look there was a damn
secret I guess that's what these boxes
are here for put in the water I suppose
Oh or not oh now this is what I'm
talking about
there's something here get out of here
yeah why can I pull that but not the
other one this guy's a wood not nearly
as muscular as I am muscular but
really is this the way out
wait no I've then I'm then I'm missing a
whole bunch of stuff I'm gonna hold off
on going down there because I've been
kind of sprinting through stuff without
catching what I need to catch cuz this
is sort of the mod where you can just
yeah I can just sort of like skip over
up
oh how gonna get me now gonna get me how
am I gonna get back off okay
HUP Oh bleep ah yeah I want to check out
this room see what's the deal with this
oh nothing okay that's fine then I
suppose got a chair
a dog in a dog head was this a dog head
why do I need a dog's head Oh
again a room with no purpose a gear am I
supposed to get this gear for something
the machine may be baby and see that's
what I'm that's what I'm thinking of
there's like that machine why why did
machine get pointed out to me must have
been important for some reason right
right maybe not maybe I'm just an idiot
and I'm wasting time nothing on the bed
okay all right I'm gonna take that gear
and I'm gonna assume that there's
something to do with it which is
probably a stupid assumption on my part
pop Oh bleep oh oh oh dump
Oh dumb oh way oh boy boy didn't know
splash no bar oh there it is just took a
second to decide come here buddy
oh it's so sad for you see there's tons
of stuff out here ah this is where the
Machine needs ah this is where I need to
put the gear see see if I'd have just
rushed ahead I would never not gonna do
what I thought I was gonna
therefore as is to be as therefore in
the other countries of them as is and
therefore they are boink
whoops boink tada
set it couch Oh
bask in my glory of Awesomeness I'm just
so amazing
I saw the puzzle before I even know what
the puzzle is oh hello the new cogwheel
that you ordered has been placed in the
Foreman's office try not to break this
102 okay okay
oh that hint would have been useful a
few minutes ago
boom boom used to be steam flow now what
did that do I am wondering steam I guess
I'll follow the pipes I suppose Oh
epic ooh yeah gather wave rocks and
cares about you rocks okay let's try
this again Oh 360 ah that sounds low oh
and then it just stops there why why
all I needed to go to the other side of
my bad I supposed to go over there
because that's where I can jump over but
it don't matter cuz there's a bridge
right here okay that's right
oh no no OOP OOP three-tier cake almost
180 all right now it's team oh this
seems lost oh now I'm supposed to go in
the hole
I bet if I'd gone farther than hole it
would have stopped me I suppose
okay all right whatever
it don't matter it don't matter it's all
the same it's all it's all rigged it's
all one big joke okay No
laughs right left right right no oh oh
no why why why why why why why why they
do that to me why would why would they
do that
why do that [ __ ] mannequins oh I hate
him I hate him so much
I hate I hate mannequins I hate
mannequin
oh hey Manny oh no matter
Clym you just escaped my fate
Oh
it isn't gonna shiver up my fine when
rice seasoned statues Anakin's oh two
points gimme gimme red three boys yeah
oh oh oh I hate him I hate him so much
I I don't know why I just do
I hate no see this type of chair often
Oh
you can't protect me chair knowing can
protect me from mannequins oh I'm okay
I'm okay I'm okay
back to toughness back to super
toughness I'm so brave and tough and
brave again why did I turn on the
machine
oh oh this open along with that open
block that up nice good
no mana kids go pop out there it's gonna
be like y'all I'm gonna be like oh and
then it's a monster I go hast a monster
oh okay rinse my face oh my gosh so so
bad
oh that's not open either oh good okay I
need the West prison peed open this door
okay whatever you say man whatever you
say
okay I like that
can I like that there we go okay oh yes
hah present key is it the West oh oh
it's just a monster okay oh I need a
boxes baby boxes can't see me
oh stop making noises boxes oh shut up
can't see me oh oh okay it's okay
there's a monster monsters can't hurt me
wait no way mannequins can
okay all right is he going oh he's out
there now okay good
ah he just knocked on the door and
didn't even come in the room okay he's
gonna leave soon he's gonna leave soon
come on music tell me he left soon
just leave sticking around
oh oh okay he's okay it's okay
you going the other way I'm doing fine
I'm doing fine
shut up whispers shut up shut your mouth
yes as a very effective put wooden
boards on that structurally sound okay
so he just had to knock down the door
though he's just gonna be all I think
he's just gonna be patent for a bit so
crappy huh
it's going back just gonna wait till I
get behind him and once I get behind him
then I gotta go I gotta just run right
for it like a big baby like a big baby
big blubber bear okay
okay okay okay okay okay okay okay okay
okay come on where is he ah come on he's
so slow all right
I'm actually out of time for this
episode so thank you all so much for
watching I will sprint past him in the
next episode bye bye hey